Jessica Roth reacts to Logan Paul's now
infamous YouTube video it was definitely
a lapse of judgment in late December the
YouTube star received backlash after he
uploaded a video which appeared to show
a dead person I don't expect to be
forgiven I'm simply here to apologize
the 22 year old issued multiple
apologies but is still under fire and
now his co-star in the upcoming flick
valley girl is weighing in we're so
excited for valley girl but Logan Paul
has gotten into a lot of controversy
what's your reaction to that and what is
the cast reaction event um you know I
think I was heartbroken to see that that
happened and I my experiences with Logan
on set were always incredibly positive
and wonderful I think it was definitely
a lapse of judgment but I also think
that the movie and the work everyone did
in the movie speaks for itself and it's
an incredible incredible film one that
we're all really proud of and I'm just
excited for people to see it
ET was with Roth and her co-star Alex
Rowe to talk about their new romantic
movie forever my girl nothing's going to
happen between us
I never said it was and he dished on
what it took to prep for his role as a
country music superstar
when people hear you speak they might be
surprised to hear you how did you get
into that country vibe I listen to the
country country artists kind of being
interviewed and talking about their life
and and I just listen like just just be
watching that over and over and over
again at all different types so it was
just by osmosis trying to take it I
listen to as far as music goes I
definitely listen to darks Bentley and
Brett eldritch a little bit too I tried
to listen to a little Chris Stapleton
but we kind of agreed that I wasn't
gonna be able to sing night Chris tape
recorder yeah I love singing but I kind
of loved in this movie that Josie's
totally removed from that world I think
it's important for their relationship
it's important for the arc of the story
but Alex worked his butt off there yeah
my Bob fellow
[Music]